Hey, this is really weird.
Speaking of cases, Donald Trump now says he
is honored, not horrified, not concerned.
Trump is honored that we in the United States
have by far the most corona virus infections
in the world.
This is extremely odd.
Here is the man himself saying it.
So when we have a lot of cases, I don't look
at that as a bad thing.
I look at that is in a certain respect as
being a good thing because it means our testing
is much better.
So if we were testing a million people instead
of 14 million people, we would have far fewer
cases.
Right.
So I view it as a badge of honor.
This is absolutely crazy.
Trump.
Trump talks about this as an honor.
He's not really honoring the victims or their
families when he continues to just flippantly
remark about we've we've passed the peak.
We figured it out.
We're the best.
We've got the most has the best test.
We've got all the equipment.
We've got all the different stuff.
We're reopening.
It's all great.
We did so well.
He doesn't seem to be honoring anyone.
And Trump continues to be completely confused
about testing.
He keeps talking about raw numbers.
We've, you know, a million tests, 14 million
tests.
Let's give this some serious thought, because
this matters.
You know, Trump's wacky comment about a badge
of honor from having the most infections.
It's not some is bonkers off the wall cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs.
But let's use it to actually get informed
about things.
Let's not just dismiss it as the rantings
of a lunatic, which it is.
But Trump's idea is we have so many infections
because we have so much testing.
OK.
Let's explore that.
Let's look at the numbers of the five million
global confirmed coronavirus cases.
The U.S. has about 1.6 million.
So what we have in the U.S. is 32 percent
of the cases, but we only have 4 percent of
the population.
So the cases are out of sync with our population.
Now we have more cases than the next.
I think it's six countries combined globaly.
The case numbers are crazy.
But do we have the most cases because we have
the most testing?
Well, not really in the sense that our testing
per capita is still only thirty eighth in
the world.
So what Donald Trump is claiming doesn't make
any sense.
And we still are only testing about three
hundred and seventy five thousand people per
day.
I sound like a broken record.
I've told you many times now we should have
been at 500 thousand a day more than a month
ago.
We need to get to five thousand five hundred
thousand a day to eventually get to one and
a half to five million tests per day.
That's what you need to really be doing, significant
surveillance testing where you would say,
listen, regardless of symptoms, if you are
65 or older, you need to get it.
Go and get a test this week.
OK.
Next week, if you are between 55 and 65, go
and get a test.
You need one and a half to five million tests
today to be able to start doing that kind
of surveillance testing.
We are nowhere close to that even still.
Let's move on to the next analysis.
Maybe most importantly, there is no doubt
that case numbers do depend on testing, even
if the U.S. is only 38 per capita in testing.
But deaths do not depend on testing.
And when you look at deaths per capita, the
United States is 12th highest in the world
in deaths per capita out of more than one
hundred and eighty countries.
As Donald Trump often likes to say, our deaths
per capita, not total deaths now.
OK.
Well, of course, we're number one in total
deaths, but that's that's different.
We're talking about deaths per capita deaths
per capita.
The United States is the 12th highest out
of more than 180 countries.
So a lot of people have been writing to me
saying, David, you've got to talk about this
with Joe Rogan.
Next time you go on.
I do hope that this comes up next time I go
on and talk with Joe Rogan about it.
I want to get the data out there.
And the frustrating thing about this is that
it's shocking how many people are making claims
about cases, deaths, testing without understanding
that you can just go find the data very often.
I will tweet a screenshot of testing numbers,
per capita deaths, you know, whatever.
Right.
I'll tweet it.
And in the risk.
Ponce's people are responding to things where
it's implicit that we just don't have access
to a bunch of this data.
The data's available.
And one of the things that, you know, if I
get an opportunity at some point soon to talk
with Joe Rogan about this, it's not going
to be about attacking anyone or proving anybody
wrong.
It's going to be to point out that we don't
have to speculate about a lot of this stuff
because we have the data.
Now, if you want to argue there is something
missing from the data or the data is inaccurate
in some way.
I welcome that discussion.
It seems increasingly when we look at places
like Florida that the inaccuracies go in favor
of those who want to pretend that this is
no big deal.
But I welcome the opportunity to do that.